Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir à toutes et à tous.
Je suis ravi d’être avec vous
ce soir à La Baule au TEDx 2022.
Nous allons parler d’une immersion
un peu spéciale.
Une immersion qui vous concerne
toutes et tous.
Une immersion qui va vous donner
une nouvelle façon d’exister,
qui va vous offrir de nouvelles
perspectives de rencontres sans frontière
et qui va avoir un impact sur vos vies
personnelle et professionnelle.
Revenons sur une date importante.
En 1978,
mon cher Papa revient d’un magasin
que vous connaissez tous, la FNAC,
ça existait à l’époque,
avec un gros carton
et un ordinateur personnel à l’intérieur.
C’est un Apple II - pour certains,
peut-être que vous l’avez eu en main.
Et du haut de mes neuf ans,
je pose la question :
« Est-ce que cet ordinateur
répond à toutes mes questions ? »
Et la réponse est bien évidemment non.
Les logiciels qui sont intégrés
dans l’ordinateur
sont les seuls à répondre à ces questions.
Mais je suis d’une génération bénie
puisqu’en 1993, l’Internet arrive
et est disponible pour tous.
Et là, on peut accéder
à des informations de façon illimitée.
Non content de cette nouvelle liberté,
et après avoir passé beaucoup d’années
à faire de l’évangélisation
de technologies émergentes,
je me disais qu’il manquait peut-être
une petite épaisseur à cet Internet.
Le destin m’amène, il y a dix ans,
à une démonstration
qu’on me fait sur un univers 3D
qui est exécutable
dans un navigateur Internet.
C’est hyper impressionnant,
c’est beau, c’est hyper fluide.
Mais il y a un gros problème,
c’est que cet univers-là,
il est complètement vide d’humanité.
Donc il fallait trouver une société -
elle n’existait pas -
qui était en capacité de vous offrir
une nouvelle identité digitale.
Et on a monté effectivement
la société Silkke.
On vous offre cette identité digitale
sous la forme d’un avatar ultra-réaliste
qui est doué d’intelligence et d’émotions
et qui va vous permettre d’interagir
dans ces univers immersifs
et d’interagir avec le design 3D,
mais certainement encore plus
avec vos semblables.
On parlait déjà à l’époque,
il y a 10 ans, de métavers.
Je vais demander à un ami, Geoffrey Camus,
qui est mannequin de profession,
un mannequin français connu
qui a écumé les podiums
dans le monde entier,
de vous exposer son avatar 3D Silkke.
Voix : (Anglais) Je suis un Silkke.
En tant qu’humain numérique,
je m’appelle Geoffrey Camus,
mannequin 3D haute-fidélité.
Je suis le leader d’une génération qui
se sert de sa nouvelle identité numérique
pour partager et vivre
au sein d’univers 3D.
Je suis entièrement équipé et prêt
à me téléporter dans des contenus 3D
en quelques secondes
et interagir avec mes pairs.
Propulsé par l’intelligence artificielle,
je peux devenir mannequin,
artiste, créateur,
être n’importe où n’importe quand.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que j’ai été produit
dans une capsule Silkke,
un appareil créé
pour n’importe quel humain sur Terre.
Désormais, tout le monde
peut tirer avantage
de sa nouvelle identité numérique.
Rejoignez notre communauté Silkke
et bâtissez avec nous
le futur de l’être numérique.
ED : Qu’en pensez-vous ?
Ce n’est pas fabuleux ?
On serait aux États-Unis,
on dirait « amazing ».
Non ?
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Cet avatar,
il a été réalisé de façon
complètement automatisée.
On aurait pu penser,
quelques années auparavant,
qu’il aurait fallu pas mal d’ingénieurs
dans des studios de gaming
pour créer cet avatar.
Mais notre solution, c’est d’offrir
à tout le monde, à tout un chacun,
cette identité digitale.
Comment ça fonctionne ?
Il est rentré de façon très ludique
dans une sorte de cabine
qu’on appelle la capsule,
qui est une sorte d’ascenseur,
de téléporteur vers ces mondes immersifs.
Il s’est positionné au centre,
il a écarté les bras
et il y a 200 capteurs photo
qui ont pris une photo.
Ce pod de téléportation
que nous allons
déployer dans le monde entier
est en capacité de faire passer
60 personnes à l’heure dans cette capsule.
Vous imaginez, 60 personnes à l’heure,
c’est un équivalent de production
de 180 000 avatars à l’année
sur un marché qui est estimé à cinq ans
à 700 milliardsde dollars, je crois.
Ce sont des études du Gartner,
du Crédit Suisse,
qui l’ont déjà démontré
depuis un certain temps.
C'est une courbe exponentielle.
Si on imagine qu’on aura tous besoin
d’une identité digitale
pour interagir dans ces milieux immersifs,
il va falloir qu’on en construise
quand même pas mal des capsules.
Une fois les photos arrivées
sur notre serveur,
je vais vous expliquer
un peu le processus.
Ces photos, en fait, sont ordonnancées
pour créer une enveloppe corporelle
et on va de façon automatique
positionner le squelette
sur la partie corporelle et labiale.
On va remplacer les yeux.
On va rajouter une trachée, une dentition,
et ainsi on va livrer
une nouvelle identité digitale
que seul Geoffrey a le pouvoir d’utiliser.
Parce que notre sujet,
c’est bien de redonner la propriété
de la data à chacun d’entre nous.
Vous allez pouvoir faire,
comme lui, un peu de kung fu,
mais vous allez aussi pouvoir
embellir votre avatar.
Parce que l’industrie de la mode,
comme vous avez vu dans cette vidéo,
est en train de produire en masse
des collections de vêtements 3D
qu’on va pouvoir positionner
sur nos avatars dévêtus.
C’est un sujet majeur puisqu’on a réussi
à avoir une table de correspondance
entre toutes ces collections
et ces tailles
avec n’importe quelle corpulence
de l’avatar.
Et vous avez vu comme c’est beau, comme le
vêtement vit avec l’animation de l’avatar.
On a une grosse promesse
aujourd’hui dans ce secteur-là.
Vous imaginez le marché gigantesque
qui s’offre à nous sur cette idée.
Mais l’histoire ne s’arrête pas là.
Imaginons que vous créez
une collection d’avatars,
tous plus beaux les uns que les autres.
Vous allez alors entrer en immersion
dans le métavers pour créer du revenu
et valoriser votre notoriété.
Vous allez rendre votre avatar
de plus en plus habile et intelligent
et suivre un apprentissage
qui est calqué un peu
sur ce que vous vivez dans la vie réelle.
On pourrait même adosser
une monnaie à cet avatar.
C'est une idée dont vous allez entendre
parler très prochainement.
J'ai toujours pensé que la mixité
était une grande richesse.
Quand j’étais adolescent, j’aimais
organiser des soirées, des fêtes,
avec mes amis, dans le garage familial,
et voir mes amis sportifs,
mes amis musiciens,
mes amis intellos, mes amis tunisiens,
mes cousins américains,
les amis de mes amis,
mêler leurs origines
et leurs passions respectives
pour créer ces instants de communion
qui font avancer le monde.
À l’image de Jules Verne qui mettait
en avant la science et l’exploration,
je suis persuadé qu’on va tous aller
fortement dans ces univers immersifs
en y apportant notre
meilleure intelligence.
Voilà ce qu’est cette immersion
dans les mondes immersifs.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)